penicillin vaccines organ transplants
all these innovations are rightfully
hailed as medical milestones
but if you ask me another invention we
don't really talk about in these terms
more than deserves to be held in the
same regard
[Applause]
the toilet i'm speaking about the toilet
[Music]
you should give a crap about your
crapper because it has a huge impact on
your life and humanity in general
many of us take modern sanitation for
granted at best
at worst it's an icky subject to be
avoided due to what
you know goes in there
but that's exactly the point it goes in
there and then it vanishes
like you know didn't happen that's
amazing
for the vast majority of humans that
have walked the earth once they had done
their business they were kind of stuck
with it
and that's by no means a problem of the
past even today
many people around the world don't have
access to adequate sanitation
that has dramatic consequences from
disease to violence
to a negative impact on the local
economy the market sector itself
actually has huge economic potential
the sanitation industry is a
multi-billion dollar
business that goes well beyond the
toilet into
the collection and the treatment of
waste and the production
of products that can be reintegrated
into global supply chains
but let's not get ahead of ourselves
where did it all start
throughout history sanitation more and
less sophisticated
appeared and disappeared repeatedly the
earliest facilities we know of
appeared around 5000 years ago in places
like today scotland
crete and most impressively pakistan
the indus village civilization was
living in
today's pakistan they actually had
water closets in their own houses
and the water supply entered also each
each house so that the civilization
had water and sanitation concept which
is quite similar what we are using today
the first major breakthrough in modern
loot technology came when sir
john harrington invented the flush
toilet in the late 16th century
he was an english poet member of queen
elizabeth the first
royal court and funny enough ancestor of
game of thrones actor
kit harrington
his ajax device featured an elevated
tank that emptied water into a bowl to
wash away its contents
almost 200 years later in 1775
the s-trap was patented it traps a small
amount of water in the drain to prevent
sewer gases from rising up
aside from minor updates down the line
this is pretty much how modern flush
toilets work today
you push a button which opens a valve in
the tank and the toilet flushes
a floating device lowers and eventually
opens another valve
letting new water flow into the tank
when it's full you're ready to go again
but the toilet itself is only half a
deal what really changed the game
is how we dispose of our waste after
it's left the bone
it's not too crazy to say that without
that
the industrial revolution might not
really have happened
in the mid-1800s exploding populations
and urbanization led to rampant
outbreaks of diseases in english cities
[Music]
many diseases spread because drinking
water was contaminated with sewage
the first person to discover the direct
link between human waste and an outbreak
was a physician named jon snow
no relation this time after a cholera
outbreak ravaged a london neighborhood
in 1854
he proved that several cases had
clustered around a single water pump
built next to a cesspit
which was the go-to solution for waste
management in those days
then came the great stink
that's not the title for a new pixar
fleek it's what londoners called the
horrible stench that enveloped the city
in the summer of 1858
london's waste had been dumped directly
into the thames for decades
but unusually high temperatures made the
foul odor rising from the river nearly
unbearable
this was the final straw and eventually
led to the construction of one of the
world's first modern sewage systems
when the industrial revolution started
kicking on elsewhere
modern sanitation came with it but like
with so many other privileges of the
wealth
they helped create colonized peoples did
not get their fair share
there are currently 2.4 billion people
in the world without improved sanitation
without sanitation facilities in their
home or workplace
and there's 4.5 billion people so over
half the world's population
that don't have safely managed
sanitation systems from
the toilet all the way to the treatment
of the waste
this creates a huge problem in the
developing world
where then people since they don't have
a toilet are
defecating in the open this sanitation
crisis causes several serious issues
chief among them
risks to health lack of access to
adequate sanitation contributes to the
transmission of diseases and viral
outbreaks
i was in west africa during the um
during the ebola epidemic in in 2014 and
15 and i saw firsthand
the the importance of these basic
facilities
according to a 2019 report by the world
health organization
inadequate sanitation is estimated to
cause 432
000 deaths due to diarrhea annually
open defecation also puts people at risk
of becoming victims of violence
especially women they face a higher risk
of being sexually assaulted
and these issues also have long-term
knock-on effects
it stops girls for example from going to
school
if they can't safely and hygienically go
to the toilet
or when they're menstruating then they
may not go to school and that often
happens
being unable to attend school makes it
much harder to earn a living later on
let alone escape poverty
to tackle the issue wholesale the shf is
not just putting up john's and running
into the sunset
they support communities with education
and finances to kick-start a sanitation
economy
the toilet board coalition came up with
the sanitation economy approach in 2017
and it's made up of three distinct areas
to
vastly oversimplify by combining a
marketplace for toilet related goods and
services with a marketplace for
sanitation
and a data-driven sanitation
infrastructure communities can establish
a growing self-sustaining economy
in order to facilitate a transition from
thinking about sanitation as a cost
to thinking about it as a business
opportunity we've worked with the asian
development bank and world bank to
understand the economic potential
of a thriving sanitation economy
marketplace
so we looked first and foremost at india
as an example and what we found is that
there's a market opportunity
of 97 billion us dollars in 2021 alone
another big aspect of the future
sanitation economy is innovation
so the sanitation crisis is multifaceted
and there are many solutions that need
policy and financial interventions but
there are still some areas where new
technology is needed
relatively speaking since the great
stink not all that much has changed in
how we handle sanitation
but another pressing global issue is
pushing activists and scientists to
rethink the status quo
climate change as climate changes
this can be even more challenging for
sanitation because
for example if flooding increases then
where people are relying on on-site
sanitation on pit latrines
floods can wash out the contents of
pitla dreams wash them onto the street
where obviously they're going to cause
a health hazard flood waters can destroy
uh
water pipes and other infrastructure if
there's droughts then
people might not have enough water to
operate
waterborne sewage systems
while climate change exacerbates the
issues of vulnerable sanitation
infrastructure
outdated sanitation systems in many
developed countries are worsening the
effects of climate change
flushing the toilet accounts for some 30
of a person's average daily drinking
water consumption
older toilets use up to 14 liters of
water per flush even though 3 liters
might be plenty depending on what needs
to go down the drain
in 2011 the bill and melinda gates
foundation initiated the
reinvent the toilet challenge it awarded
grants to researchers to develop
sustainable toilet technology that could
function without connections to the
public sewage systems
teams at delft university of technology
for example are using the grant to work
on a water saving toilet system that
employs microwave technology to
transform
human waste into electricity cranfield
university in the uk
used the grant to finance the
development of the nano membrane toilet
it can treat human waste without any
external energy or water
the toilet relies on a mechanism
activated by the pull of a lever
and vaporization after vaporizing the
waste the liquids are filtered through a
special membrane
recrab a recap the target has shaped
human history for centuries
and continues to do so many many people
around the world need one and we
all need new ones so next time
you take a leak before you flush maybe
just maybe pause for a moment and
reflect
on the monumental act of human
enterprise
ingenuity and perseverance you're about
to perform
but don't pause for too long that would
be weird and wash your hands afterwards